what do Prince Zuko and Jake long have
in common they are both voiced by aka
Dante Bosco that work we got I'm Dante
Bosco
I'm an actor voice actor people might
recognize my voice from Zuko who out
until last airbender please father only
at the fire nation's best interests at
heart I'm sorry I forgot a turn jake
long the american dragon yeah okay haha
no problem just sit back and watch and
read do his thing dragon up yo the kooky
movie I'm like yo Stacey talk to me talk
to me talk to me baby and a few others
like scorpion from the ultimate
spider-man and even Romeo from the proud
to most people know me as an actor I got
the whole start as dancer a breakdancer
they my brothers were street performers
in the 80s as a group called the Street
crews enough you burp on the street free
successes breakdancers community
scholarships to Sam so eloquently no man
ballet and that less selling his first
breakout role was Rufio the rebellious
triple Mohawk donning leather jacket
wearing leader of the Lost Boys you are
for factory slug slime sack of rat guts
and cat vomit don't pick up the rolling
hook after a single audition so he asked
Steven Spielberg why and he told me
after at 11,000 orchids the audition for
the role I'll do a kid that scared him
at only 15 years old
Dante gotta act alongside the late Robin
Williams just being around Robin he was
everything that she would think you
would be when he was around magical
stuff happen always I'm going to do the
first row I think me and Robin won but
how did it crumb you're not gonna says
in the script and you cry
I remember up to shooting I didn't know
what
why you can fight
[Music]
that's what I did even work perfect
after hook Dante went on to voice a
character known for one of the most
redeeming journeys in animation history
Prezi Co bad boy turned goodbye the end
for the Fire Nation its angsty teenager
and trying to figure out what's right
and wrong for him in life and that's
sole character art there's a theme that
follows me and my characters it looks
like through my life and as Prince Zuko
Dante got the experience of a lifetime
working with Mark Hamill aka Luke
Skywalker I grew up as a Star Wars fan
like everybody out there the door opens
that's Mark Hamill and he just looks
like hello and I'm like man I'm
fangirling inside and for people that
don't know this scene between Zuko and
his father
Ozai we finally find out how the Zuko
gets us big scar on his face that he has
throughout the whole series and we're
doing lines like father no father I
won't bite you I will not fight you oh
my god I just did the Vader Luke scene
with Mark Hamill and I was playing Luke
Skywalker neither playing Darth Vader it
was the most surreal moment of my my
career and it is amazing whether you saw
his face or heard his voice I'll take
that as a thank you
Dante is a part of our childhoods one
way or another just somewhere along the
way my voice got popular and then I'm
pretty fortunate because voice acting
became a very prominent part of
Hollywood now I mean so many young
actors coming to Hollywood to
specifically be voice actors and
things wonderful
[Music]